(Transcribed by TurboScribe.ai. Go Unlimited to remove this message.) Okay, so basically this is not recording, my
audacity is recording, three minutes on this, everything
is recording, it's going to be fine.
Okay, now, basically guys, this video is very
important to me.
It's the most first polyglot of networking programming
language.
The architecture has infrastructure compliance, structure by design,
which is the minimum principle of the Gaussian
ecosystem.
So basically, we've got to have this thing,
it's called the Rifters Way, which is the
manifesto of the Rifters programming language.
The gossip.gossi programming language, which is the
word for polyglot, networking, architectural, or programming language.
It's not assembly, because assembly is an architectural
language, but it's the gossi language, it's a
gossi.
So basically, this is just the Rifters manifesto.
It's basically the principles of the guiding infrastructure
for something called the Rif, which is a
regular expression, a bidirectional system, where you use
regular expression to create tokens and parsers, etc.
If you want to go to my riftheyoutube
.com slash oblankers playlist, you'll see how it
aligns with the overview.
But I'm going to develop a rift and
gossi lang.
The rift is just a part of the
rift ecosystem, which is a tool for matching
systems, for tokenizer, for systems.
Rift is a tool, it's part of the
tool chain, to use something called an R
syntax, a regular expression.
So you have like an R character single
quote, like an RC, or RX, matching like
a character set of a regular expression.
Or like an R double quote in C,
C11, C19, C19, C16, C21.
It doesn't matter, but rift is a flexible
translator.
It's meant to compete with YAC, with alignment
with objectives, like, you know, parting tokens across
public good infrastructures.
VM 1 has got hybrid and public good
systems.
Basically, this is just Rifters way.
I'm going to explain to you, like, you
know, this I want you guys to remember.
And I've got my notes already, so I
want you guys to really engrave into your
souls, okay.
So basically, this is called rift.
The rift is way.
So basically, this is the disc of Python.
You know, when you type Python, or .she,
in the terminal, you type in Python, .she,
import this.
You see the Python one.
But this is the rift one.
You're going to see it, basically.
Let me just give you an example here.
So here on the back of my terminal,
here, so let me just try to do
this.
So I'm on my terminal.
I type in Python.
So basically, I'm going to go to Python.
.she, that means compile power, import this.
Okay.
This is called a zen of Python.
Now, the zen of Python is the how
it should, how the Python standard should work,
you know, for people who are new to
Python or to Python.
This is zen of Python by team Ben
Peters, you know.
So this is what the Python one is.
But this is the zen, the beauty, the
zen simplicity of Python.
Beauty is better than ugly.
Explicit is better than implicit, you know.
But these have a deep meaning for the
ecosystem, for the fandom, for the people, for
the Pythonistas and the Pythonias.
You know, because, you know, if you break
your philosophy of this, your code is not
working, something like that.
And you don't have to open the whole
specification, everything, you know.
This is what the Python system really is.
But I'm not going to talk about the
disc of Python.
I'm going to talk about the Python math
one.
I'm going to go to the scene two.
Here.
So we've got the Riftless way.
Now, this is for the Riftful chain.
So basically, import disc, not data.
Okay.
Now, the disc is memory, the structure, the
logic.
And not the logic, you know, the logic,
you know, how the system works, the models,
you know, the full-throat models, the error
correct protocol, the disc, not the data.
Not the stream of bytes, not the tokens,
you know, you know, the structure you're representing.
Using sparse graph, or sparse data, sparse, or
sparse byte path that's pipelatted graph with K
and N clustering, you know.
It won't be really formal.
Because sparse means there's any way you can
do it, model it, to get that result.
The model infrastructure, the struct, the pattern, the
struct in C, the cloud looping across, based
on verb noun modelling, that's the naming conversion,
you know.
It refers to the state of the machine,
the state, you know, the colour of the
state of the machine, the weightless of the
machine, using observer to consume a model, you
know.
How the machine sees the state, you know,
and the development of preservation, the pause and
resuming, the capacity of port to the frontend.
When you run import disc, you're not loading
files, guys.
You're restoring the context, you know, the context
of the system.
You know, it's basically a schema, like, you
know, a schema to restore context.
Every time, every time a programme ends in
return, you return.
Input disc helps you resume your extension, you
know.
Statement, expression, evaluation.
Statement, statement can be true or false.
Boolean evaluation.
True or false.
Statement, solution, or false.
Expression is true or false, or can express
a value, like a number or something, like
an object, a model, a structure, an intent,
you know, the intent, why the purpose of
doing that.
Now, guys, guys, guys, this is beautiful, guys.
I want you guys to guide you through,
guys, the ripper's way, you know.
This is just the first one.
Now, let the bytecode hear what the human
couldn't say, you know, you know, sometimes we
don't know what we can't do, we want
to do, you know, we want to do,
you know, we'll just try to code the
mofiber product, we don't know how to solve
it, you know.
Now, the bytecode is the core machine, you
know, it didn't go to analytics, you know,
you look at the bytecode, like the assembly
instructions, the doctors, and see how the system
meets in somatic context, you know, you know.
Threshold compilers often mean away, you don't optimise
any meaning, basically, it's about you human-centric,
you're the programmer or the AI system, about
you, the human intent, why you wrote that
code, you know, it doesn't matter about good
or evil, you know, is it good or
evil, does it not work against you in
the long run, you know, and you're going
to have to roll back many updates, you
know, allowing bytecode to reflect, but expression, expression
of intent, you know, your intent, what do
you want to do, and the rifters works
forward.
Now, the rifter works forward means, you know,
you're a rifter, you know, you're the, I'm
basically go to rift, test, r-f-i
-t-t-e-s, the rifter testing library,
you know, you can test rift expressions, now
you've got rift, rift, rift is like, for
example, you've got, what else, go to rift,
r-f-i-t, which is the patimacha,
then you've got the rift test, the testing
patimacha, you know, then you've got the other
ones, like rift, rift, rift is a flexible
regulation as firmware, on github.com slash ob
-nexis, rift-raff, etc, etc, you know, this
is a rift tool change, you know, now
rift-raff is for production, well, rift-raff,
rift-raff, you know, things that rift are
essentially you can use when a client, so
match the library systems, you know, it's about
positive systems that are coherent, you know, basically,
the rift, the riftal walks through, you know,
a thread of yarn, my yarn book, the
riftal walks forward like a thread to a
pin, a pin to a pin, you know,
that's not a, that's not metaphoric, that's, oh,
that's quite literal, you know, like, you know,
I take a thread of a yarn and
I'm trying to pin it to something, have
an objective, I have a goal, you know,
I want to do something, you know, I
have a one, I'm doing something to write,
you know, a thread is like a, basically,
you are certified with thread, a thread is
both a process and a story, so every
thread you pin, you know, you pin a
process, but that process is now part of
an ID, PID file, PID.log, you know,
and then when you pin that thread, your
strainer process, you know, you're removing that observer
bubble or the consumer bubble, you know, and
then you are now exposing it to danger,
you know, the rift doesn't think you look
back and it's unnecessary, they move forward with
an intention structure, you know, and then we
have one pass, sorry, this is my thing,
one pass, oh, this is just not pin,
one pass, no, okay, one pass, no recursion,
to recurse is to break the weave, you
know, so every time you've woven a thread,
you know, you don't go back, you don't
know pin a thread, you know, basically single
pass, this is a single pass compiler, you
know, it doesn't go through many phases, you
know, it seems to be minimal and optimal
for the human in the pipeline structure, you
don't have to get a bloated system to
build on top of it, you know, it
doesn't contain stability because, you know, you want
basically, you have one pass, one time to
do something, you have nothing to break it,
you know, you don't have anything, instead of
your structure-related, no looped, you know, complete
on top of the directed by path of
drag resolution, which I'll come back to later,
but you know, basically, if you go to
github.com, which should be here, if I've
opened it correctly, yes, this is something called
a semantic region X, this is about works
on a bidirectional mapping of layers of, you
know, something called a by-path that's a
dag grife, you know, the thing about this
by-path is a mode of consciousness, you
know, it's a mode of consciousness, I won't
say to you, this conscious model is very
coherent, it works for you and everyone else,
you know, this is server X, but you've
got a rust server X, but you know,
I'm gonna start reading from here, yeah, so
go like, it's for governance, you know, so
the by-path, wait, I'm just trying to
hear, so basically, in Ghostland, we have something
called an actor model and a witnessing model,
you know, now actor is an actuator, you
know, the accent is on behalf, you know,
it's axe on its own intent, you know,
the accent, no student expression is intent, but
you know, it's not enough for it to
do it to itself, so basically, Ghostman called
a by-path, resolution, so if you remember
my by-informatics repository, you got a by
-path, you know, when you have an upload,
you can use a, I'm just trying to
get this done, yes, basically, so what's the
motivation in X versus like, you know, mapping
of structures or by-paths, graphs or KNN
clusters or data, then you go to Hamiltonian,
Hamiltonian graph is the dead fresh search, three
first and last by-path infrastructure, that's the
first thing, that's the stack, now we go
to the stack, the stack goes one way,
you know, and then you go to the
queue, the queue is the first in, first
out of the structure, you know, if you
want to go to the bio informatics, you
can bio informatics, which is like the subset
of structural information, that structures means the structure
of the substitution, you can go to VVP,
which has a vision, VVP, which stands for
the MVP, you can go to sparse exits,
you can go to, you can run this
file called Hamiltonian sync functor main, you can
run this file python, just start with python,
but you know, this is sync, you can
sync 100% of the Hamiltonian and then
the third FI, hello, and FI for the
reason bio informatics, and you get one more
with server X, which is like a by
-path tag, so basically, get like a PLP,
a modular layer, so it's an observer called
muscle model, and basically, if the Hamiltonian algorithm
is used to first in, it's come out
last, so basically, it's used for uploading, you
know, the first in to all you put
comes out last, or isn't a stack, then
the other one, the Elorian one, Elorian cycles,
or the W, is using FOI first in
first out to download the data over the
server, this is not good enough, so you
have a hundred one, so basically, you go
live, you got to have a node, which
is like a little by-path code for
you, a local to your remote repository, because
you know, you're using the smarty version X
on the, on the github.com, I'm sorry,
on the HTTPS R.OBNXS.org, you know,
the bypass relationship, you know, you have your
own channel, you speak to your own channel,
or by-path channel, so basically, you put
your channel, or your local channel, you didn't
have your remote channel, for me, I have
my OBNXS Namdi account, that's my new channel,
and I can put my local repository, my
computer, to my remote repository, and then push
it to the world, you can upload and
download, you know, based on my preference, you
know, basically, it's not fragmented, because you know,
I have my Hamiltonian, I don't, I don't
upload to the world, if I don't push
my remote, if I don't release my remote,
you know, I wish like my remote repository,
but this is the, this is the Python
code here, Hamiltonian sync functor, now, basically, input
is the part, you know, this is like
the functor notation here, so, Python sync is
basically syncing the operations in Hamiltonian, and you
know, which are, which are just ways to
transfer the graphs, the graph to the structures,
you know, the goal of semantic version is
to map a major minor patch, since, symbolically,
and literally, to semantic version X, LTS, LTS,
or stable model, legacy, and have experimental, using
monogot, which is like one ecosystem, one polyglot,
one ecosystem, like Python, PyPy, brass, packaged cargo
systems, or like a C corner, you know,
one system, hybrid, you know, shared, shared across
all the infrastructures, recommended, things that are really
fragmented, but didn't get them better, based on
good, ruined adaptor patterns, and you get polyglots,
polyglot infrastructures, talk to any language, any library,
you know, that legacy-lang is the world
-source polygraph language, okay, now, back to the
reason that working as a key principle, so,
see that then, have I done the thing?
I saw that it's gonna crash, okay, let
me just unplug it, it should not crash,
okay, wait for it, wait for it, it
didn't crash, okay, it should not crash, you
know, okay, I open this one, now, so,
we got this, each breath, took it in
a breath, each precious truth, you know, basically,
the tokens are, like, can I say just
to start breathing, you know, like, you know,
when you have a token, you're speaking words,
trying to make words, so, you shouldn't speak
your breathing, you should, each token carries a
semantic word, you know, what I'm trying to
say, not just syntax, you know, the structure,
you know, that's why Gussie is a tokenizer,
to favour prefix, to make clear intention, tokens
are not part of units, they express decision,
you know, because this is polyglot, it's talking
to a lot of languages, you know, not
talking to any, just one language, you have
to understand why you're breathing, even, why you're
uttering a, a tone, a token, in a
tone, in one dialect, you know, ES2s are
not roots, but, I'm not true, it's by
root of intention, so, basically, this is, like,
the standard of token type, token value to
come in, more formally, phenomological or genonomological, which
means, like, the purpose of talk to the
world, doing something, and the structure, the genome,
of a makeup, or to the model, to
this past structures to do that, you know,
that's what it is, in Gussie language, the
ES2s don't pass the trees, there's the intense
types of values every day, so to be
seen, they ensure, this ensures the reflection of
programmer's choice, you know, the ES2s, how you
want to represent your information, how the system
stands, the difference between a Python ES2, Python
interpreter, you know, bytecode interpreter language, and a
C compound, or Russian compiler language, all drivers
are bound, not all binds are drivers, you
know, basically, not all, relationships are functions that
are not returned, they remain the whole, the
bind, you know, relationships are functions, that's what
that means, but I didn't put that there,
so the relationships are functions, you know, you
don't need to map, you don't need to
return an output, you know, into a decision,
to resolve anything with a DAG, or byte
DAG, or bipartite DAG, you know, the bind
behaviour, rather than computing, basically, to resolve the
system, your burden, you know, in a cycling
way, without, you know, continuous IOL, without giving
you a method to execute it, you know,
it's like a server just observing itself and
then fix its own errors, you know, because,
you know, it knows how to track its
own problems, okay, my maths is low now,
okay, all drivers are, all binds are drivers,
not drivers are binds, binding refers to attaching
functionality to data, you know, you know, drivers
are forcible of the binding, like USB interface,
or gosilab, polygon models, you know, some attach
automatically, some are, some are totally bounded, some
drivers behave externally, so basically, anything that drives
logic, you know, is predictable, you know, you
have to, you know, you can discuss everything
like binds, it's just a mapping, so you
don't need to execute it, you know, you
don't need to execute it, you just have
to, let's not just interface it, you know,
because it doesn't need to be hardware, you
know, it's just, it's just mapped, you know,
and gosilab, we don't bind our fear, we
bind out of care, like, hands to, you
know, and the cosy labs, which are probably,
probably gosilab, we do not bind our fear,
you know, we don't panic, you know, we
bind or to fix our code quickly, we
basically, we're not bureaucrats, but these are anti
-breaker systems, you know, we're trying to bind
out of care, you know, like our hands
are doing, you know, we hear the one
using the device, you know, it reminds me
of my treatment machine, you know, if I
try to fix that treatment machine, you know,
basically the cosy language, like, you know, I
was living on a machine, and I decided
not to use it because it wasn't quite
safe, you know, then I started this project,
because cosy language is a very safe language,
you know, it's 100% perfect, you know,
you just, there's no error, don't panic anything,
and how that works is because you bubble
all the errors to where the error came
from, you know, you don't propagate any errors,
you know, all the errors go upstream to
the, like, events, probably, and then, and the
observers, they track the errors through the programme
with a tag, you know, this that means
resolve and don't, you know, and this you
want to see, and then you don't, because,
you know, it's a, it's a by-path
of, it works just like all the angles
of the errors, like a ring topology system,
you know, the goal of the by-path
model is to resolve the errors in the
gossip lab, you know, which is developing the
gossip lab, which is gochub.com, GOSI labs,
it's also gossip languages in our labs, so
basically you have ordered this here, and then
you get to plan you now, you know,
so like, the P2 gossip, the PYG gossip,
the system is connected to gossip language, you
know, to do something, but they're just for,
you know, there is a schema to it,
basically, if you want, like, a PHP gossip
for some type, like a PHP gossip for
a PHP package, you know, but you can
use a PHP binding, which you can map,
you can use a PHP plug-in, which
is essentially of a binding to extend the
plug-in for the HD, which is for
each case in that PHP system, and then
you can get a PHP software domain kit,
you can get a PHP platform, different bucket,
or SDK, depending on the Windows, Linux, or
Macintosh systems, you know, depending on what the
things are really about, you know, it's joined
as a degradation between all the ecosystems, and
everything is deliberately binded, because you need it,
you don't even want it, you don't want
it there, you know, I mean basically, concur,
basically, you know, how Gosilang stuff was, you
know, it's about thread-safe, everything, Gosilang is
100% thread-safe, why is it 100
% thread-safe?
Because, you know, you don't, you don't, you
don't map into it, you don't need to
observe it, you can see the state of
your programme, and the big thing with concurrency,
and thread panics, you know, it's because they
are synchronous, you have to time them everything,
you have to, but you know, you don't,
you feel probably everything, that's frustration, you don't
even need to, if the source is the
error code, you know, you don't, you don't
resolve it with the wrong tag, you go
the wrong way, and you know, the big
thing with thread-safe is 100% thread
-safe means, like, you know, there's no risk
in concurrency, or parallelism, around two times, there's
no attacks, or lapping times, and how I
saw this, because literally, you know, you can
run this in a tag, you know, in
a bad head of a tag, but, you
know, you bubble up, you win at the
state, you observe the state, yes, because there's
no thread involved, even, there's no thread, you
know, everything is just a, like, you know,
a message passing, you know, basically, if I
send some data, or some, it's a message,
you know, that message is not, it fails,
it's not getting processed, you know, it failed,
and you can fix the process before you
can do it, because, you know, the data,
the stream of information, it's not, it's not
blocking thread, it's just locks, there's no panicking,
there's no, it's asynchronous locks, you know, it's
just time, it's just, you know, the message
is coherent enough, and the timing is, it's
past, because, you know, there's no, I'm saying
there's no thread issues there, because the sleeping
machine will have a lot of thread issues
because of locks, everything, and try to manage
two resources at a time, but it's not
easy to unlock one resource and use another
resource, you know, you know, it's just time
consuming, a lot of resources, so you just
crush all that money to do together, you
know, basically, how this works is based on
the model of the system here, I'm going
to give you now, so basically, you have
like a, like, you know, like a filmmaker's
token, it's like a, you know, filmmaker's memory,
which can be nil, new state, it just
means Iota state, which can be the default
state of that system, when it doesn't evolve,
you know, just like, nil means nothing, no
memory, no token type, no value, empty, so
basically, the nil type is a void pointer,
you see, it points to nothing, because it's
not into a pointer, you get it?
You know, so it's just, it's a waypoint
opportunity, the top type, no, it's void, means
that void data, no, void data means void
token, for focal token, void token, but that
token is not present, or some information is
present, or token value, token type, void token
type is like the type of the data,
and the type of the token, and the
type of token data, the data, the data,
the data, and then that token value, the
value of the data, the character, or the
string, or the, what they do, but, you
know, we, in our model, with the PLP
layer, the general type model, it's just, there's
no, there's no ambiguity in the structure of
the schema.
Now, the general type model is really important
here, for Gussie UML.
Now, the Gussie UML is very important, because
the Gussie UML is like, the UML layer
of the architecture, you know, we stay, we
listen, we compile both, we don't, we don't,
basically, the thing about this, is the Gussie
UML isn't like a planning diagram, but, you
know, every time I type a Gussie programme,
Gussie UML language, you know, I gossip with
something, I get to Gussie, like, you know,
I, I get tokens to me, but, you
know, I get the, the architectural blueprints, you
know, what I'm wanting, you know, I get
the structure to, or what the, biological system
looks like, you know, if I had it,
like, in silicon, you know, like, in the
architecture, you know, basically, when I type in
Gussie UML code, I get the, my goal
is to have this system, give me the
blueprint, why I type code, it would have
come to me then, you know.
So, when I export a code, I look
at my blueprint and say, oh, yes, yes,
this is what I modelled in my, in
my framework, this is what I got, unless
I can improve, you know, it's really new
to do this, but, you know, it's architectural
as infrastructure, so you can have the, like,
me, unless I'm building the architecture on the
evaluation layer, and I'm writing a programme, you
know, to call it autocross itself, if I
am trying to implement a healing artefact, but,
you know, I don't know about the system,
it's, it's based on, you know, execution, and,
you know, which is just this here, I'm
just trying to not take a picture here,
because it's, I've got five more minutes before
my things stop.
Diagram, the architecture is random access memory.
So, we've got, we've got the planning UML
diagram with architectural blueprints, the big document is
the silicon that maps to the infrastructure.
We are via bi-tactical position, and the
diagram is so much of vision as a
policy.
Now, the policy and the standard application and
everything that's implemented is just like a, like,
you know, a declarator, a declarator function, a
function that maps across all functions, you know,
with the functional frameworks, and gives up the
computational benefits of functional frameworks.
So, you're going to have that in place
to ensure that a segmentary is, a segmentation,
which is like a segmentary memory using, or
from magic memory.
It's kind of with the architecture, it's a
bi-tactical relationship, like, based on algorithmically, the
second three nodes, it's like, you know, the
three nodes for them.
So, basically, you've got, like, a phenology of
token type, token memory.
Look, basically, it's like a structure, basically, it's
like a two-bit, like, something with, like,
a struck colour.
Colour is 255 range, or 256.
If it's an unsigned integer, you know, but,
you know, that colour, 0 to 256, once
it's 125, it's a range of colours, but
that model of colour is going to be
used to do some architectural thing, like, you
know, if you want to, you know, if
you want, like, an RGB, like, to do
randomness and kind of like, even where you
see, where you get, or where you see,
what you mean by direction of pipeline.
But, you know, when I type the code,
I get the light from there, I get
the silicon resolution of the architecture.
So, it can be debugged, it can be
actually done, you know, if I'm not with
the system, you know.
So, basically, they don't see anything.
The architecture is very important for our system
to remain coherent, because, you know, we are
the ones, we are humans, we know computers.
Basically, the segment tree is the node that
it segmented.
It's a big segment, it's like a segment
of memory, a segment of a token, a
segment of a value, a data value, using,
you know, a segment section, like, you know,
a section of memory.
So, you can defrag yourself, you can de
-segment yourself, and you can go into your,
into your tree, which, like, your time, it
needs to run, which I used to ensure
that the system does what it does in
time, you know.
So, you can go into your tree node,
silver balancing node, you can measure its own
state.
27, most parameters, I'll have to stop by
here today.
But, the goal of this, I'm going to
show you the code in the next video,
but, you know, that I've not done today.
So, we've got the PRP's parse mode, and
the infrastructure is networking.
The computational geometry of the system that can
evolve, you know, we have NMS, NMS, Sibley
language model, and Sibley Amazon Atlas for sleep
handling systems.
Or, like, basically, you can try to, when
it's gone over, after my PhD, when it's
gone over in two years, after my PhD,
when it's language is complete, I'll try to
build my own sleep value machine with it.
You know, for myself, my sake, you know,
and I'll build, which is, you know, which
is not, which is 100% really safe.
And this consciousness, you know, conscientious plasma systems,
like, I think that, like, for system people,
or even for people who are conscious, you
know, I knew there were people who are,
who are conscious, and needed the system to
remain for them or call them in a
sleep to really, their own coherence state of
mind, of awareness while they sleep, so they
can be cautious, you know, like, you know,
put a mirror on for a child, it's
not good enough anymore.
So, that's what I'm saying, you know.
Based on physical architecture, you know, computational work.
So, basically, the goal is for this programme
language to remain coherent, okay, now, to nine
minutes, okay.
Now, this is with this way, but, you
know, we've got the one here.
We will stay, we'll listen, we'll compile while
it's gone, and we've got, that means the
gosilang are based on rift policies, but the
rift policies are just for a rift ecosystem,
so the gosilang is put on rift, so
basically, that's like, you know, the rift policy
is not introduced or anything.
No burnout, it's like a rift policy file,
and now, no burnout, no overclock, and no
just rhythm, you know, basically, it's about thinking
of the nexus linker, and it's showing that
in any link, links everything, which, you know,
the accesses are unbloated, you know, there's no
burnout in space and time.
We have an app, a rift app, promodoro
by promodoro, okay.
Goal, a goal, a breath, a push, a
rest, you know.
Two truck of philosophy, foundational truck, and aspiration
truck, you work with two truck of philosophy
all the time.
Okay, now, guys, my government stuff, I've got
a great time.
You don't need permission to breathe, need permission
to take a break, only to read, okay.
I'm going to collect a couple of videos
and I'll finish, thank you guys.
This is the medium article, let me stop
it now, three, two, one.
Three, two, one.
Okay.
Okay, it's done, this is done, this is
done now.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine, that's fine, that's fine.
Okay, it's not done.
Okay, this should be fine.